thank you for joining us America this is
the Dave Ramsey show in the lobby of
Ramsey solutions Cody is with us hey
Cody how are ya I'm great Dave how are
you better than I deserve welcome
welcome where are you from I'm from Iowa
City Iowa cool welcome to Nashville good
to have you so you're here to do a
debt-free screen I am I love it and how
much have you paid off sir I paid off
$15,000 in about eight and a half months
good for you making what kind of money
about $45,000 so what do you do for a
living I'm an engineer and I manage
construction projects good for you and
what kind of debt was this 10,000 of it
was on federal student loans and the
other 5,000 was on a car I bought last
year okay so I'm guessing you got out of
school got the big job somewhere around
a year ago and then tore into this is
that the plan yep about back in February
my family is on the way to Colorado
about a 12 to 13 hour drive for a ski
trip and I was locked in the car with my
sister reading me the complete guide to
money about that whole entire trip so I
heard that whole entire book I it was
driving me nuts
I was bored out of my mind that's
torture and slowly throughout the months
following that I started listening to
podcast a little more I got a lot more
interested decided that once I started
making little more money it was time to
get it under control and and be where I
want to be well when you decide to go
after you went after it didn't you yeah
yeah that's pretty serious you're like
you're you're hammering this yeah the
first couple months I was doing the
budget I only put about five hundred a
month towards the debt and then as I
started catching traction I decided to
quit adding to that retirement fund it
went up to 1,000 1,500 and I paid off
over 3,000 in the final month Wow it
started moving along really fast so the
intensity increased so how old are you
I'm 23 and you have no debt you have a
four-year degree and you're working
you're working as a construction
engineer yep it's only uphill from here
man I'm telling you this is awesome you
have got it you got it going on it's
very cool so how does it feel cuz you
just decided to take control of
something and you did it I mean that's
pretty pretty impressive it feels good I
think doing this plan didn't only change
me money-wise it gave me
were confident a lot of other areas of
my life before I was I was always kind
of frugal but I was never willing to
spend money because I was afraid to
spend the money and now that I'm
budgeting and doing that I I know where
the money's going and I don't have any
problem spending it because it the
budget actually gave me freedom yeah so
you know if you're 53 or you're 23 when
you suddenly take responsibility of an
area of your life you didn't before it
does it gives you it grows you up in
that area gives you a sense of maturity
a sense of destiny doesn't it exactly
yes it does very cool very proud of you
man so I'm guessing your sister who
trapped you in the car and read this is
proud of you
yep and she's here with me today the
audio book lady is here yes that's right
she started it right about that time too
and I think they're kind of seen a lot
of the same results so very cool very
cool
well thanks for coming all the way from
Iowa to do this I'm proud of you yeah
happy to come you ought to be proud of
yourself this is awesome thank you all
right Cody what is the secret to a 23
year old getting $15,000 paid off in
eight and a half months I would I hate
to be cliche but I definitely say that
it's the budget like I said before I
wasn't out of control with my money but
I didn't really know where I was going
and it's funny back in June I wrote
myself a goalless and I'd have all my
debt paid off by August of 2016
well I beat that up by about five months
so the budget obviously helped a lot
cool well done well goal setters were
people who win excellent job very proud
of you Cody from Iowa City Iowa $15,000
paid off an eight and a half months
making forty five thousand a year count
it down let's hear a debt free scream
three two one
I'm dead
I love it I love it well done sir well
done
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and so you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind